يومكم مستمرون في تغطيتنا للاوضاع في
السودان ففي الوقت الذي تعهد فيه طرف
الصراع التزام بهدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام لم
يمر سوى ساعات قليله لتتهم قوات الدعم
السريع الجيش بخرقها بقصف قواتها في محيط
القصر الجمهوري رغم ان هذه الروايه لم يتم
التاكد منها الا ان الشواهد تقول ان جميع
الهدنات التي اعلن عنها سابقا لم تصمد هذا
وتتواصل عمليات الاجلاء التي تقوم بها دول
العربيه والغربيه لنقل رعاياهم من السودان
وسط مخاوف منزلاق ثالث اكبر دوله في
افريقيا نحو الهاويه اما السودانيون فهم
امام سيناريوهين مرعبين احلاهما مر اما
البقاء وسط حرب لا نذر بانتهائها قريبا او
النزوح تاركين وراءهم مصير بلد يعاني منذ
سنوات من ازمات متلاحقه اضيفت اليها اخيرا
حرب بين
اكبر قوتين عسكريتين قد يقود الى دوامه
الحرب الاهليه
[موسيقى]
السودان
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
وفي التفاصيل وبعد ساعات قليله من سريان
هدنه ثلاثه ايام المعلنه افاد مراسل
العربيه بان دويه اصوات رصاص بالاسلحه
الثقيله سمع في ام درمان وفي محيط القصر
بالخرطوم وبحسب شهود عيان هناك تحليق
طيران وضرب مدفعيه وسمع اصوات اشتباكات
متقطعه باسلحه خفيفه
هذا واظهرت الصور مشاهد تبين حجم الدمار
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم جراء
المعارك العنيفه الدائره منذ اكثر من عشره
ايام
[موسيقى]
نتابع معكم جميع الاخبار المتعلقه في
السودان وفي بيان الاخير للجيش السوداني
بعد ان دخلت الهدنه يومها الاول وساعتها
الاولى ولكن حدثت خروقات في صباح هذا
اليوم في السودان الجيش السوداني يقول
بانهم يحتفظون بحقهم كاملا في التعامل مع
خروقات الدعم السريع للهدنه في ظل اتهامات
كل من الجانبين بانه هو من كان بادئا في
خرق الهدنه التي اعلنت واقرت منذ ليله امس
ايضا الجيش السوداني يقول بان مجموعات
الدعم السريع تحاول استغلال الهدنه لانقاذ
موقفها العمليات
المتدهور كما قالت الجيش السوداني يقول
بان مجموعات الدعم السريع نشرت القناصه في
مناطق متفرقه من الخرطوم والولايات طبعا
هذا كله يتزامن مع ما سمع من ذوي لاطلاق
قضائف وايضا اطلاق نار والشبكات في وسط
العاصمه السودانيه في الساعات الاولى من
صباح هذا اليوم في الخرطوم بعد اقرار
الهدنه التي تم الاعلان عنها هذه الادنى
التي تلت هدنه عيد
ساعه نحن الان امام ايضا اثنتين 72 ساعه
اخرىين تم فيها الاعلان والموافقه من قبل
الاطراف والقوى العسكريه على اهدنا عسكريه
بينهما اذا نذهب قليلا ونبتعد عن اخبار
السودان ولكن سنعود اليها وهذا هو خبر
عاجل ايضا مهم رسميا بايدن يعلن ترشحها في
انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه 20 24 اذا هذه
هي المعلومات التي تاتينا من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه طبعا كان هناك علامات
استفهام وايضا تساؤلات حول ان كان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن سيعلن ترشحه في
انتخابات الولايات المتحده 20 24 طبعا
نذكر بان الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب كان
ايضا اعلن ترشحه في انتخابات 20 24 وهو
يعتبر بانه المرشح الجمهوري الاوفر حظا
للنيل بان يكون الرئيس
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه في عام 20 24
طبعا كل هذه التصريحات وكل هذه التطورات
التي تاتي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في ظل عدد كبير من المتغيرات الى طرات على
الوضع الداخلي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وايضا فيما يتعلق بالسياسه
الخارجيه لامريكا اذا ما تابعنا ايضا جديد
التصريحات التي تاتينا على لسان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن هو يقول بان الحريات
الشخصيه في امريكا تتعرض لهجوم مما
اسمائهم المتطرفين الجمهوريين اذا من
الجمهوريين المتطرفين كما يقول بايدن هذه
تصريحات تاتي بعد اعلانه رسميا لترشحه في
انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه 20 24 طبعا
بعد ان فاز الرئيس جو بايدن في انتخابات
الرئاسه قبل اربعه اعوام حصلت هناك ردات
فعل في الشارع خرج الناس من الشارع من
مناصريه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب طبعا
دونالد ترامب ومعاونوه كانوا طالبو بنتيجه
الانتخابات وايضا طلبوا باعاده هذه
الانتخابات في ظل توجيه الاتهامات بانه
حصلت هناك تزوير وبالتالي حصل ما حصل اشتد
الشارع واندلعت ايضا الاحداث المشهوره في
احداث الكابيتال في العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن وحتى اليوم هناك اتهامات وايضا
توجيتهما لمحاكمات بالرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب ومن بينها احداث
الكابيتال نعود اذا الى احداث السودان حيث
اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت قوات الجيش
باستهداف مواقعها قرب القصر الجمهوري
بالخرطوم وقال بيان دعم السريع ان هذا
الاستهداف يعد انتهاكا للهدنه المعلنه
مؤكدا ان القصف العشوائي للجيش يهدد حياه
المدنيين ورعايا الدول الاجنبيه في
الخرطوم كما اشارت قوه دعم السريع في بيان
الى ان كسر شروط الهدنه المعلنه يؤكد وجود
اكثر من مركز قرار داخل قياده الجيش واعاد
دعم السريع تاكيد على الت زامه بشروط
الهدنه لفتح ممرات انسانيه المدنيين
والمقيمين الاجانب
[موسيقى]
اذا سنعرض لكم هذا الفيديو لاعلان الرئيس
الامريكي اذا ينشر هو هذا الفيديو الرئيسي
الامريكيه جو بايدن الذي اعلن قبل قليل في
تصريحات بانه يترشح لانتخابات الرئاسه في
عام 20 24 انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه
ويضيف بايدن بان الحريات الشخصيه في
امريكا تتعرض لهجوم مما وصفه من
الجمهوريين المتطرفين طبعا نتابع معكم هذا
الفيديو الذي كان نشره الرئيس الامريكي
طبعا كل الصور التي تجري ونشاهدها في هذه
الصور وهذا الفيديوهات وكانها مشروع من
الاستحقاقات التي اراد بها الرئيس
الامريكي تحقيقها خلال ولايته وما يريد
ايضا الاستمرار بها ان كان وصل الى
الانتخابات رئاسه في عام 204
لولايه ثانيه نتحدث عن اربعه اعوام اضافيه
هو ينشر صوره في البيت الابيض يتحدث بانهم
يريدون المزيد من الحريه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التعبير كما هو مكتوب
في اسفل الفيديو وايضا المزيد من حقوق
المواطن الامريكي كل هذه الصور وكانها جزء
من الدعايه الرسميه التي نشرت فيما يتعلق
وتتزامن مع اعلان الرئيس
ترشحه الانتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه
المقبله في عام 20 24 نعود معكم الاخبار
السودان دانت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه ما
وصفته باستمرار نهج قوات الدعم السريع
باستهداف السفراء ودبلوماسيين ومقر
البعثات الدبلوماسيه ووصف بيان الخارجيه
السودانيه قوات الدعم السريع بانها
ميليشيا ارهابيه بات الضالعه في ترويع
المواطنين وقتل واستهداف المدنيين البيان
حذر من استغلال الدعم السريع للهدنه في
نشر قواته وارتكاب مزيدا من الانت هاكات
بحق المدنيين الخارجيه السودانيه اكدت
سيزام الجيش بالهدنه تاكيدا على حرصه
لحمايه المدنيين واحترام القانون الدولي
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من جانبي طلب مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريلا طلب الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بالتزامي في
الهدنه التي اعلناها لمده 72 ساعه بشكل
كامل وقال بوريل في تغريده النوى على
تويتر ان الهدف هو التوصل لوقف دائما
للاعمال العدائيه واقامه ممرات انسانيه
لحمايه المدنيين
ونستمر معكم في هذه التغطيه ونذهب الى
شبكه ضيوف العربيه الكرام نبدا اولا من
الخرطوم معنى من هناك الصحفي سامي محمد
سكرتير عام نادي الصحافه السودانيه استاذ
سامي مرحبا بكم معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه
هل عادت الاشتباكات بين طرفي الصراع
المسلحين رغم الهدنه التي اقرت ليلى امس
الاثنين
اهلا وسهلا الاشتباكات افضل تتوقف الا
ساعات قليله
لطبيعه قوات الدعم السريع تستطيع القوات
التحكم فيها هي قوات ليست اهيل عسكري عالي
وزاره انضباط تحت لواء معين فمن الصعب انك
تقدر تتحكم فيها الغائب لسلوكهم
[تصفيق]
يكون متمركز في اماكنهم تحصل المناوشات
لذلك يصعب حسم المعركه عسكريا اليوم سامي
حتى نفهم الكثير من المعلومات والتفاصيل
طالما انتم يعني موجودون على الارض اليوم
سامي حجم الخروقات للهدنه من خلال
معاينتكم على الارض في اليوم الاول
والساعات الاولى كيف يمكن مقارنتها مع هدن
سابقه اعلنت واقرت
ليس هناك اختلاف كثير بالامس كانت برضو
ايضا الهدنه كانت الهدنه ايضا وكانت في
مناوشات في منطقه جبره ومنطقه منطقه دبره
ومنطقه الشجره اليوم برضو الاستمرار في
الهدنه التي دعوا لها الامريكان لمده 72
ساعه برضو
مناوشات حصلت في وسطه الخ
رطوم الخرطوم فليس هناك
يفهمون معنى كلمه الهدنه
لكن الى انه نرجع ونقول انه
ساعات قليله خلال النهار وخلال الليل تكون
هناك هدنه وترجع الحياه للاسواق الطرفيه
في المدينه الخرطوم وكما ترجع المواصلات
جزئيا في مدينه وهذا منحى ايجابي يدل على
وجود الامن قليلا للاماكن التي تحت سيطره
الجيش
يعني الان في بيان للجيش السوداني قبل
قليل يتحدث بان مجموعات الدعم السريع نشرت
قناصه في مناطق متفرقه من الخرطوم
والولايات وهي ايضا تواصل تحركها داخل
وخارج العاصمه السودانيه رغم الهدنه ما
الذي يجري هل من معطيات اكثر تفاصيل حول
ما قيل في بيان الجيش
بيان الجيش وهو اول مره الجيش يسبق في
البيانات الدعم السريع ويطلع بيان كمبادره
ويوضح ما يحصل الان في الوضع الراقي
لا نقدر ان نكذب او ان نصدق
او ان نصدق هذا البيان الى ان المعطيات
الان بالاشتباك الحاصل نقول ان الجيش هو
حاليا هو يدافع عن نفسه لانه منتخب قلب
الخرطوم
والمناطق السياديه كامله هي
عمره الجيش لانه هو الجيش هزم الدعم
السريع فيها واخرجهم كامل منها فيبقى
طالما حصلت المنوشات داخل منطقه غلب
الخرطوم وقريب من الاماكن السياديه مثل
القصر الجمهوري
ويبقى هذا تعدي واضح ومن الدعم السريع
لخرق الهدنه
طيب سامي اليوم ما حجم القلق ودقه
التحذيرات من ان من ينجو من القذائف
الطائشه قد لا ينجو من السلب والنهب وقطع
الطرق في السودان
من خلال الايام الماضيه السلب وكسرت
الترويع الامني
من السجون وعدد من المجرمين ومن المحتاجين
الاجرام ثم اطلاقهم وهم
لا انه يكون في حالات كثيره من الناس
والانفراط الامني الزائد هو ما يولد هذا
وعدم وجود
عدم وجود الحركه الدائريه للاقتصاد للعمل
وغياب البوليس وهذا شيء
شيء محيط القانون السوداني يفرض على
البوليس على البوليس انه هو في حاله الحرب
انه يكون تحت امرك
يا سامي اليوم في اطراف اخرى بدات تستفيد
من هذه الفوضى الحاصله اليوم في السودان
المنطقه الصناعيه
واماره الذهب في قلب السوق العربي من سلبي
والكثير من الاماكن المتفرقه الاماكن
التجاريه في قلب الخرطوم وفي الشارع
المشتل برضو عدد من الاماكن التجاريه سلبت
بالكامل هذه اموال مواطنين بعد اختصاص
سوداني هذا
[تصفيق]
تدمير تدمير للمواطن السوداني سواء كان
سودانيا او سوى كان اجنبيا ترى ان اموالك
كلها بتسحب هباء في في حرب لك انت فيها
ولا جمل فهذا ما يدل على السيره نحن نطالب
بعوده البوليس الى الشوارع وخوفه وكما قال
القانون السوداني البوليسي حاله الحرب
يعامل معامله الجيش ويعامل الضابط
البوليسكا بنفس امتياز بعض الجيش هم
يكونوا في قلب المعركه ويحفظوا هذه الامن
هذا واجبهم وهذه اموال وهذه اموال هذه
اموال المواطنين واجبهم
الى جانب الامن هل الجهود الانسانيه
المبذوله كافيه لتخفيف وطاه الازمه على
المدني السوداني اليوم
الوضع الانساني محرج جدا في السودان
الكميه من الجسد
مرميه على الشوارع
ثلاثه ايام اربعه ايام من اتخذت وحاليا
تصبح في مرحله خطره سندخل في الامراض
الوبائيه التي تخرج من خلال الجثث المتعف
الامداد الامداد الاطباء غالبيه الاطباء
يعانون من مشكله كيفيه الامان للذهاب
للمستشفيات كيفيه الخروج من المستشفيات
هذه اشكاليه كبيره
لماذا مازال هناك عدد كبير من الجثث ملقاه
على الارض في الشوارع هل بسبب ان الطرق
غير امنه للوصول اليها ام في اسباب اخرى
يعني يتم
في اماكن الحروب
ومن يقدر ان يخرج من بيته حتى يقوم بواجب
انه دفنه هذه الجثث من منع العقيقه هذه
هذه المسؤوليه
طيب
العمل مسؤوليتها الكامله ليس هذا مسؤوليه
المواطن طيب اليوم كمان الى جانب هذه
الازمات الى اي حد حرب السجون هو مصطلح
حقيقي واقع اليوم ام انه مبالغ في خصوصا
مع هروب عدد كبير من المساجين الفرين
وبعضهم كان محكوم عليه بالاعدام
من هذه القوات كما في عدد في عدد من
الفيديوهات وكما هذا عدد من الناشطين
الذين كانوا متواجدين داخل السجون انه
تهجم على السجون وفتح ابواب السجون كامله
الثلاثه سجود
طيب استاذ سامي يعني نحن نحاول ان نفهم من
قدر الامكان الوضع حتى هذه الساعه على
صعيد ميداني
من ازمه امنيه
واضحه جدا
اصبحت كل شخص يعرف حتى على منزلك لا
بد ان سلامتك باي طرق ممكنه
طب كيف
عدد
هربوا باعوا مقابل الطعام ومقابل
المواطنين يعني مما لا شك فيه من كلامك يا
استاذ سامي بانه الوضع في العاصمه صار
خاطر للغايه يعني لا ابسط مقومات الحياه
غير متوفره وحتى الحاله الامنيه يعني لا
امن ولا استقرار طيب اليوم اذا اريد ان
اتخيل يعني كيف يعيش المواطن السوداني يا
استاذ سامي خصوصا الذين يعيشون اليوم في
العاصمه
وغالبيه غالبيه الاسر السودانيه الاسر
السودانيه تفكر في الهجره والنزوح
عن هذه الخرطوم هذه الخرطوم اصبحت مدينه
الاشباح اصبح الطرق لا يمكن ان تمشي فيها
بامان لا يمكن ان تتغذى حاجتك لا يمكن ان
تكوني جالس في منزله بامان هذه الفرقه
الامنيه يعاني منها غالبيه الاسر
وهذه اكبر نقشه وقعت على تاريخ السودان
اكبر
الترويع والنعم والسلب على ممتلكات
المواطنين هذه اكبر نقشه
بتاكيد سنكون معكم في سياق هذه التغطيه
على العربيه نكتفي بهذا القدر وشكرا لك
الصحفي سامي محمد سكرتير عام نادي الصحافه
السودانيه شكرا
تتواصل حركه نزوح المواطنين من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم الى ولايات البلاد
الاخرى وتشهد العاصمه حركه سفر ناشطه عبر
حافلات وبساط في اتجاه بعض الولايات
كالبحر الاحمر والجزيره وقد تراوحت اسعار
التذاكر بين 20 الى 50,000 جنيه سوداني
بعدما كانت لا تتخطى العشرين الف جنيه قبل
اندلاع للشبكات
هذا هو الميناء الشمالي بمدينه بورسودان
بولايه البحر الاحمر بشرق السودان هنا
تستمر عمليه الاجلاء لمئات من رعايه الدول
العربيه والاوروبيه والاسيويه التي بدات
من الخرطوم العاصمه برا الى شرق السودان
ومنها عبر البحر الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبعدها يغادرون الى دولهم عمليه
الاجلاء تمضي تحت اشراف كامل من قبل الجيش
السوداني عبر مسارين بحري وجوي وكانت
العديد من الدول العربيه والاسيويه
والاوروبيه قد شرعت في التنسيق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في الترتيب لاجلاء
رعاياها خلال الساعات الماضيه
في هذه المرحله من مراحل عمليه الاجلاء
التي بدات هنا في شرق السودان يتم الوصول
الى هذه المرحله وهي مرحله الاستوثاق من
الاوراق الثبوتيه ومن الجوازات هنا تقوم
الشرطه السودانيه ممثله في اداره الجوازات
والهجره بالتعرف على كافه الاوراق
الثبوتيه وجوازات السفر تمهيدا لنقلهم
واجلائهم عبر الباخره الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومنها الى بقيه دولهم هنا
292 من رعايه دوله الهند بالسودان اكمل
اجراءات مغادرتهم واجلائهم من مدينه
بورسودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومنها الى دولتهم فيما ينتظر اخرون
استكمال اجراءاتهم لمغادره البلاد خلال
الساعات المقبله نزار البغداوي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث الميناء الشمالي مدينه
بورسودان شرقي السودان
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت الحكومه البريطانيه
بدا اجداء رعاياها من السودان وذكرت
الحكومه ان طائرات عسكريه بريطانيه ستقلع
من مطار خارج الخرطوم تباعا من جانبه قال
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس انه لا يمكن
اجراء سوى حاملي جواز سفر البريطاني
وافراد اسرهم مضيفا ان الاولويه ستكون
للمرضى او العائلات التي لديها اطفال او
كبار السن
[موسيقى]
تحركنا من منطقه الخرطوم الى منطقه على
بعد حوالي 1200 1300 كيلو
صعب انك تخرج من بيتك
نقطه يعني كثير
تحت القصف كان يعني خلص كنا متحضرين حاله
ان الموت يعني باي لحظه
دعونا نذهب قليلا الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والجديد التصريحات وهذا التجاذب
السياسي الذي ظهر على لسان الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي قبل دقائق كان اعلن
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ترشحه
الانتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه في 20 24
وقال بان الحريات الشخصيه هي مهدده مما
اسماهم
بالمتطرفين الجمهوريين الان يخرج الحزب
الجمهوري ويتهم الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بالانفصال عن الواقع بعد اعلان ترشح
الانتخابات 20 24 نذكر بانه الرئيس
الامريكيه السابق دون الترامب كان بدا
اصلا في حملات الانتخابيه ويزور اكثر من
ولايه لكي يباشر في حملته الانتخابيه في
ظل الازمه القضائيه التي تلاحقه سواء في
احداث الكابتل او ايضا في احداث الابتزاز
لدفع ايضا لممثله الافلام اباحيه ملايين
الدولارات من اجل السكوت عن ما حصل اذا في
انتخابات عامه عشرين عشرين عشرين
اعلن عن ترشح الرئيس وفوزه في انتخابات
الرئاسه حينها الان تخرج هذه الاصوات من
قبل الحزب الجمهوري الذي يعتبر من الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وكانه ينفصل عن الواقع
طبعا في خلال السنوات الاربعه الاخيره
طرات الكثير من التغيرات وتطورات سواء في
الشام الداخلي الامريكي كان هناك ازمه
اقتصاديه هي ازمه يعني طالت كل العالم
ولكنها بدات بازمه الفيدرالي الامريكي
ورفع المزيد من الفوائد بالتالي حصل في
تضخم في العالم وتضخم في امريكا على
الاسواق بشكل عام وعلى الناس وحياتهم بشكل
خاص فبالتالي اذا تابعنا استطلاعات وراء
خصوصا مثلا مؤسسه غالوب العالميه الشهيره
يعني في اخر استطلاع حينما تحدثت عن
امكانيه ترشح الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الانتخابات الرئاسه 2023 كانت تتحدث عن
تدني تدني تقييم الامريكيين والمواطن
الامريكي لاداء الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن في
تعامله مع الملفات الداخليه خصوصا وان
المواطن الامريكي هو يهم من يدفع له في
جيبه يعني دائما الفلسفه الامريكيه
بالنسبه للامريكان هم لا يهمهم ما يجري
خارج حدود امريكا هذا عصعيد مواطنين بل
يهمهم السياسه الداخليه من يدفع لهم اكثر
من يحسن الاقتصاد والملفات العده كبيئه
وطاقه وشؤون داخليه فبالتالي هناك تدني
لتقييم الامريكيين في مقابل الملفات اخرى
على كل حلقه ايام القليله المقبله ستكشف
المزيد والمزيد طبعا هذا فيما يتعلق
بارشادنا الامريكي نعود الى شان السوداني
ومع توالي عمليات الاجلاء لكافه الدول
وبعض الدول اليوم نتحدث عن عمليه الاجلاء
البريطانيه نذهب الى لندن ومعلم هناك
مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو لنعرف المزيد من
التفاصيل حول عمليه الاجلاء مصطفى قبل ان
نتحدث عن تفاصيل وحيثيات عمليه الاجلاء
البريطانيه لماذا لم تسرع الحكومه
البريطانيه بعمليه اجلاء الرعايه
البريطانيين مثل ما فعلت دول اخرى مثل
فرنسا وغيرها مثلا
حقيقه هذه انتقادات وجهت الى الحكومه
البريطانيه ولكن التبرير الخارجيه ورئيس
الوزراء بان لدى الحكومه واجب عملي لحمايه
اولا الدبلوماسيين وبالتالي تم التنسيق مع
شركاء المحليين ولا سيما فرنسا ومصر
والسعوديه بخصوص اجلاء الدبلوماسيين تم
ارسال طائرتين عسكريتين في وقت مبكر من
صباح الاحد وتم اجلاؤهم الى قبرص هذا هو
تبرير الحكومه ولكن بالطبع كان هناك
انتقادات من قبل الاحزاب المعارضه لعدم
التواصل الحكومه مع الرعايه البريطانيه
وتقول الحكومه بانها تتعامل مع هذا الوضع
بشكل يعني
بشكل مخيف للغايه وخاصه وان الاضطرابات
واعمال العنف المتواصله ولكن تقول بان
كلما كانت هناك فرصه سانحه
لاخراج العالقين سيتم
سيتم العمل على ذلك وبالتالي هذا ما
سمعناه اليوم بان طائره عسكريه اقلعت من
القاعده العسكريه البريطانيه من قبرص
وباتجاه
بمدرج بضواحي الخرطوم وتم نقل يعني
المجموعه من العالقين مبدئيا تقول الحكومه
بانها كانت هناك اولويه للناس الاكثر ضعفا
بما في ذلك العائلات التي لديها اطفال
بالنسبه ايضا لكبار السن وايضا ممن هم
بحاجه الى مساعدات الطبيه نعرف بان
الحكومه البريطانيه استخدمت طائرتين
عسكريتين من قبل ولكن ربما لن يكون المدرج
كافي لاستيعاب طائرتين عسكريين عسكريتا من
بريطانيا بالعلم بان ربما دول اخرى تحاول
ان تؤمن الطائرات
لاجلاء رعايه من هناك
للوضع الراهن في السودان هل عمليه الاجلاء
اختياريه ام اجباريه بالنسبه للرعايه
والمواطنين البريطانيين في السودان اليوم
كل من سجل نفسه مع وزاره الخارجيه سيتم
التنسيق معه او معها سيتم ارسال رسائل
لابلاغهم بالتحرك الى
المطار
ولكن عمليه النقل من من البيت مثلا الى
هذا المطار يكون على حساب الشخص وبالتالي
يجب اخذ المزيد من الحيطه والحذر في في
خلال عمليات هذا النقل ومن ثم يتم التدقيق
فيه هويتهم وبالتالي يتم اجلائهم الى قبرص
ومن هناك هناك عمليه تدقيق اخرى من قبل
وزاره الداخليه قبل ان يتم تنظيم رحلات
مدنيه من قبرص الى المملكه المتحده
المصطفى هل حصل الجانب البريطاني على اي
ضمانات هل من قنوات اتصال مع طرفي الصراع
لضمان تيسير عمليه الاجلاء البريطانيه
بطريقه امنه اقله
بالفعل ليس فقط مع الاطراف المتنزعه في
السودان بل ايضا مع الشركاء الدوليين في
المنطقه يعني يجب التنسيق مع هؤلاء لان
العمليه جد معقده ويمكن ان تتغير هذه
العمليه بين لحظه واخرى وبالتالي لم تعطي
الحكومه ضمانات بان جميع الرعايه
البريطانيين يمكن اجلاؤهم من السودان
حاليا لدى المملكه المتحده يعني تاكيدات
بحوالي 2000 شخص تم التواصل معهم عالقون
في السودان ولكن هناك تقديرات بان يصل عدد
الرعايه البريطانيين
الجنسيه الى 4000 نعرف بان الهدنه يعني
الهدنه الجديده هي تمتد لثلاثه ايام ولكن
يعني ممكن ان يتغير الوضع وبالتالي
استخدام طائرتين حربيتين او عسكريتين تتسع
لما يقارب ما بين 120 الى 200 شخص بحاجه
الى عدد من الرحلات وبالتالي يعني الحكومه
يعني تصارع تصارع الوقت والزمن لمحاوله
اجلاء اكبر عدد ممكن بالطبع هناك من لا
يريد ان يغادر السودان لاسباب يعني شخصيه
ولكن المجمل وان الغالبيه العظمى سيتم
اجلائها من من هؤلاء المحاصرين في السودان
طيب مصطفى هل بعد اتمام عمليه الاجلاء
البريطانيه لمن هم ما زالوا في السودان
يمكن الحديث عن تبلور موقف بريطاني
للمساهمه في مبادرات ما ضغط ما ازاء
الازمه الحاصله اليوم في السودان
هذا ما سمعناه من المسؤولين البريطانيين
وايضا مع بالتنسيق مع شركاء المحليل
لاسيما فرنسا مصر السعوديه الولايات
المتحده لارغام الاطراف المتنحره على وقف
يعني وقف هذا الاقتتال والعوده الى
المفاوضات لان المفاوضات هي التي تخرج
البلد من هذه
المحنه بالاضافه الى دعم عمليه الانتقال
الى حكومه مدنيه مستقره هذا ما تريد
يعني السلطات البريطانيه ان يحصل ولكن
بالطبع يعني بالتنسيق مع شركاء الدوليين
سيتم ارغام الاطراف المتنازعه على وقف هذا
الاقتتال لان الوضع الانساني يعني سيكون
كارثيا ليس فقط للسودان بل ايضا ربما هذه
الماساه ستمتد الى الدول المجاوره وهذا ما
يخشاه المسؤولون البريطانيين وتعمل
الحكومه على مساعده الاطراف
بالاضافه الى تقديم الدعم لكل من يريد ان
يساهم في وضع حد لهذا النزاع في السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه التفاصيل من
لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
اما على الحدود السودانيه المصريه لجا
الكثيرون للدخول الى مصر عبر معبر ارقين
حدودي هربا من النزاع الدائر فيما افاد
مراسل العربيه بان غالبيه حافلات الاجلاء
القادمه من السودان تتجه الى مطار اسوان
ونذهب مباشره الى معبر ارقين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه مراسل عربيه احمد عثمان
اهلا بك احمد معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه كم
يقدر اعداد الذين وصلوا الحدود المصريه
السودانيه عبر معبر ارقين حتى هذه الساعه
يتوجهون الى مدينه اسوان التي تبعد حوالي
500 كيلو متر يعني ربما حوالي خمسه ساعات
اخرى من خلال الحافلات او السيارات كثير
من السودانيين الذين تحدثنا معهم اكدوا
بانهم سيفضلون الانتظار في مدينه اسوان
لاكثر من سبب السبب الاول هو ربما لمراقبه
ما سوف تتجه اليه الامور في السودان
تطورات المشهد الامني والسياسي هل سيكون
هناك تثبيت لهذه الهدنه ووقف لاراقه
الدماء حتى ليتمكنوا من العوده مره اخرى
ام انهم قد يتوجهون بعدها الى اماكن اخرى
مثل القاهره او غيرها من المدن هناك
الكثير من الاقارب والاصدقاء في مدينه
اسوان وبالتالي هذه المنطقه ستشهد يعني
كثافه للكثير من السودانيين خلال
المرحلهم وتسمع تفاصيلهم وروايات قصصهم
حول عمليه الن زوح هذا واللجوء لعبور
الحدود المصريه هل ربما استوحيت بانهم
يعتبرون عبورهم اليوم رحله مؤقته لمده
لبرهه من الزمن ام انها روحه بلا عوده في
الوقت الراهن
يعني هذا السؤال سالته بالفعل كما ذكرتي
بهذه التفاصيل للكثير ممن تحدثت معهم
بدايه الكثير منهم يعني ربما يشعر بنوع من
الارهاق فتخرج الكلمات مقتضبه الكثير منهم
يشعر بنوع من الغضب ولا يريد الحديث وربما
يعني يريد ان ينسى ما شاهده خلال الساعات
او الايام الماضيه ربما يتحدثون عن المشهد
المستقبلي البعض تحدث عن روع مراه ولكن
هناك من يرى بان ربما الاولويه الان هي
فكره الهروب من ما راوه من وقف لاطلاق
النار الكل يتحدث عن الساعات حتى الاخيره
فكره رحله الوصول الى هنا الى الحدود
المصريه هذه الرحله عبر الحفل
يعني المرور ببعض الاشتباكات وبعض الحديث
في مرحله التامل يعني لفتره قبل ان يكون
هناك قرار للعوده لكن يكون هناك
اطلاق النيران خلال المرحله المقبله وليس
وقف متقطع او يعني ربما شامل للعوده مره
اخرى احمد بتاكيد سنكون معك في السياق هذه
التغطيه شكرا لك حتى هذه اللحظه من معبر
ارقين على الحدود المصريه السودانيه
قبل ذلك وجهت مصر اعضاء صفارتها في
الخرطوم بعدم التحرك الا لحالات الضروره
كما شددت الاجراءات الامنيه حول سفارتها
بالخرطوم واعضائها منذ ليله امس وذكرت
مصادر العربيه ان هناك تنسيقا مع الجانب
السوداني لفتح تحقيق في مقتل مساعد الملحق
الاداري بعد ان طلبت القاهره مزيدا من
التوضيحات حول ملابسات الحادث قالت
المصادر انه سيتم نقل جثمان مساعد الملحق
الاداري على احدى طائرات المصريه لدفنه في
مصر
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
اعلن رئيس الفرنسي ايمانيال ماكرون اجلاء
538 شخصا من السودان بينهم
حتى الان جاء ذلك خلال تراس ماكرون اجتماع
مجلس الدفاع والامن الوطني حيث تمت مناقشه
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان
من جانبي اعلن رئيس وزراء الياباني ان
فرنسا نقلت ثمانيه مواطنين يابانيين من
بينهم مسؤولون بالسفاره واسرهم من قاعده
لقوات الجويه في شمال الخرطوم
في اعقاب اجلاء خمسه واربعين شخصا الليله
الماضيه بطائرات تابعه لقوات الدفاع
تلقينا في وقت مبكر اليوم تقريرا يفيد بان
ثمانيه يابانيين مقيمين في السودان بينهم
مسؤولون بالسفاره واسرهم غادروا من قاعده
وادي سيدنا الجويه الواقعه الشمالي
العاصمه الخرطوم بمساعده فرنسا سنمضي قدما
من خلال المكتب المؤقت الذي اقيم في
جيبوتي سوف نستمر في التواصل عن كتب مع
الدول المعنيه وسنبذل قصار جهدنا لضمان
سلامه المقيمين اليابانيين في السودان
وتقديم الدعم الضروري
[موسيقى]
في السياق اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
اجلاء معظم رعاياها في السودان عبر
مجموعات الى الموانئ الحدوديه بالدول
المجاوره وقالت متحدثه باسم الوزاره ان
بكين لم تتلقى اي تقارير عن سقوط ضحايا
صينيين بالسودان حتى الان
اعلنت القوات المسلحه الالمانيه اجلاء
حوالي 100 شخص اخر من السودان بمن فيه
مواطن المانيا ودول اخرى ليصبح مجموع
الاشخاص الذين تم اجلائهم حوالي 500 شخص
من السودان الى الاردن عبر خمس رحلات منذ
بدايه الازمه في السودان واستمرار
الاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع حسبما افادت وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه دي بي اي
وفي اخر الجهود الدوليه لاحتواء التوترات
في السودان اعلن وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اعلن في تغريده على
تويتر ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ستتواصل مع الاشقاء في السودان لتامين
ممرات امنه لاجلاء رعايه دول الصديقه
والشقيقه كما اكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان
مواصله المملكه في اجلاء رعايه الدول التي
تقدمت بطلب مساعده مواطنيها ونقلها لاماكن
امنه
نذهب الى القاهره معنا من هناك لواء
المتقاعد محمد عبد الواحد الخبير الامني
والمختص بالشؤون الافريقيه مرحبا بكم معنا
اللواء محمد في سياق هذه التغطيه تقييم
لليوم الحادي عشر على التوالي للمعركه
المتصاعده في السودان هل ستصل الى حرب
استنزاف عسكري ممكن ان يتوقف الطرفان
نهائيا اقل لفتره لحين التفاوض
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بمشاهدينك الكرام فعلا
اليوم الحادي عشر وما زالت المعارك مستمره
خاصه في العاصمه الخرطوم
المعارك لا تهدا حتى في فترات الهدنه كل
طرف يحاول انه ياخد استراحه مقاتل ثم يعيد
من ترتيب اوراق ويعيد من حصوله على الدعم
اللوجستي من الخارج
المعارك الحقيقه في السودان معارك غريبه
الى حد ما لان الجيش السوداني بيستخدم
فيها الاسلحه الثقيله وهي لا تتناسب مع
البيئه السودانيه خاصه في المدن الجيش
السوداني لديه طائرات بقتله والطيارات
حربيه لكنها غير متطوره وبالتالي لا
تستطيع التعامل مع المباني السكنيه
والشوارع الضيقه وهكذا يتعامل مع دبابات
ومدرعات ومدفعيه ثقيله وهذا امر ات خيل قد
ابيض غير الحديث ماذا لو كانت حديثه الى
اي حد ايضا هناك صعوبه يعني حرب الشوارع
هل ربما تنجح فيها اكثر وتستطيع التمتع
اكثر الميليشيات الجماعات المسلحه اكثر من
جيش نظامي منضبط عموما
الاسلحه الحديثه احيانا ممكن استخدمها في
حتى في الاماكن الضيقه زي مثلا الاسلحه
الذكيه او حتى الطلقات نفسها اتغيرت عن
زمان بقت اصبحت طلقات ذكيه هي اكثر دقه
يتم تصويبها من خلال منظومه الكترونيه من
خلال اقمار صناعيه او من خلال التوجيه
المباشر لكن في الاسلحه الثقيله القديمه
احيانا تصيب وتخطئ وبالتالي دي هتسبب راي
عام سيء ومضاد تجاه الجيش السوداني في
المنطقه على الجانب الاخر القوات الدعم
السريع بتستخدم حرب العصابات تجيد هذا هذا
النوع من الحروب او نسميها حرب المدن وحرب
الشوارع لدي قدره سريعه على الحركه بدات
تستخدم حتى الدراجات البخاريه والناريه في
تحريك افرادها ونقل افرادها ودي بيصعب
معها
المتابعه او بيصعب معها
لكن العمليات العسكريه مستمره ربما
تتصاعد خلال الايام القليله القادمه بناء
على يعني حجم الاجلاء اللي احنا شفناه
بقوه والذي جاء بوتيره متسارعه وشهد زخم
اعلامي شديد اتخيل ان حتى ان هذا الزخم
ربما يكون مبالغ فيه
لتوجيه الانظار الى الحاله السودانيه ده
بيجعل ان البعض داخل السودان بيشعر بنوع
من الريبه ان المجتمع الغربي بيتخلى عنه
ان الاجانب بتزيد من حده الاحباطات لدى
الشارع السوداني ان هناك من يتخلى عن
الشعب السوداني في محنته كمان ان هناك
انذار بعمليات عسكريه ربما تكون مفتوحه
وربما تطول عدد من المدن الاخرى بخلاف
العاصمه الخرطوم لواء وانت تحدثنا ايضا
نشير الى هذا العاجل وفق مراسل العربيه
الذي يتحدث عن تحليق للطيران الحربي في ام
درمان احدى مدن ولايه الخرطوم الثلاث
نتحدث ايضا وفق مراسل العربيه عن ذوي
الشبكات بالاسلحه الثقيله في محيط مبنى
التلفزيون بام درمان حتى هذه الساعه اذا
انتقلت ايضا الاشتباكات ودوي القذائف
والشبكات بالاسلحه الثقيله التي كانت
متمركزه في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في
وسط العاصمه في صباح هذا اليوم الان
انتقلت الى ام درمان القريبه من العاصمه
السودانيه حيث ايضا سماع ذوي الشبكات
بالاسلحه الثقيله في محيط مبنى التلفزيون
باندرمان حتى هذه الساعه وايضا تحليق
للطيران الحربي وفق مراسل العربيه هذه هي
جديد التطورات المتعلقه
بالوضع الميداني في السودان حتى هذه
الساعه اعود اليك لواء محمد عبد الواحد
الخبير الامني اللواء محمد بالنسبه
للسيناريوهات اليوم المفترضه ماذا لو احكم
الجيش اليوم سيطرته على العاصمه بشكل كامل
ما الضمانات بان لا يفتح المجال وان تكون
فاتحه لحروب مفتوحه هنا وهناك في اقاليم
سودانيه اخرى كما كان معتاد الحروب ان
تكون في اطراف جغرافيا السودان لا في وسط
العاصمه مثلا
هذا السيناريو طبعا مطروح وبقوه
القوات الدعم السريع ما زالت مصممه وحتى
في اليوم الحادي عشر مصممه على الاستيلاء
على اماكن استراتيجيه تتعلق بالسياده
تعتقد انها باستيلاء على هذه الاماكن فهي
قد انتصرت في حربها ضد
القوات المسلحه السودانيه تركز على القصر
الجمهوري وعلى المطارات وعلى مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون لكن هناك مقاومه شديده من قبل
الجيش وده بيخلي الحرب يمكن ان تاخذ مسار
اخر قد يجعلها يعني تتحول الى حرب شوارع
بوتيره سريعه وكل طرف خلال الفتره القادمه
يحاول انه يوقف خطوط الدعم اللوجستي الى
الطرف الاخر سواء غلق الطرق اللي جايه
منها الدعم اللوجستي زي مثلا طريق
بورسودان
الخرطوم وايضا الحكومه السودانيه سوف
تحاول ان تضرب اماكن الدعم اللوجستي اللي
بيوصل القوات الدعم السريع خاصه من مناطق
الغرب وتتحول الصراع الى قر وفر في
الخرطوم نسبه كبيره جدا ان ربما تنجح
الحكومه السودانيه في السيطره على الخرطوم
لكن هنا بقى الصراع ينتقل الى مدن اخرى
ده اللي هينقلوا القوات التدخل السريع
ينقلوا الى مدن اخرى لديها حاضنه او يتمتع
فيها الدعم السريع بحاضنه شعبيه اكثر على
سبيل المثال مثلا منطقه غرب السودان زي
منطقه دارفور هناك حاضنه او يعني مسقط راس
قوات الدعم السريع وهو اقليم كبير جدا
يمكن كمان
هيلاقي دعم شعبي وحاضنه شعبيه وحاضنه
قبليه كمان كما انه هيستطيع انه همم
يتحالف مع القيادات المسلحه الموجوده هناك
والتي كانت ترفض الانضمام الى الات
الايطالي مثل عبد الواحد نور او الحلو
وغيره هيلاقي حدود مفتوحه مع ثلاث دول وهو
له علاقات طيبه بيها زي ليبيا وزي تشاد
وزي افريقيا الوسطى اتخيل ينتقل قد ينتقل
الصراع الى مناطق الغرب ده في المستقبل
اذا اقفق قوات الدعم السريع من تحقيق اي
انتصارات في الخرطوم نحن نشكرك جزيلا
الشكر اللواء المتقاعد محمد عبد الواحد
الخبير الامني والمختص بالشؤون الافريقيه
شكرا لك
في هذه الاثناء اعلن مكتب الامه المتحده
لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه تقليص بعض انشطته
في اجزاء من السودان بسبب القتال الدائر
وفقه متحدث باسم المكتب الامم المتحده
اوضحنا المعارك الحاليه ادت الى اعاقه
العمليات الانسانيه مضطرهم الى هذا القرار
مؤكد ان الامم المتحده ملتزمه بمواصله
تقديم المساعده لشعب السودان
من جانبها اعربت منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
قلقها بعد 11 يوما من القتال في السودان
اكدت ان المنظمه تعمل مع شركائها لاعاده
مستشفيات الخرطوم للعمل
نحن قلقون جدا بعد 11 يوما من القتال في
السودان وحتى الساعه لا يوجد اي تطور لوقف
بوادر القتال ما يزيد من التحديات
الانسانيه المشكله الاساسيه التي نواجهها
هي العجز في وجود المواد الغذائيه والطبيه
وغيرها كما ارتفعت الاسعار بشكل كبير ايضا
ننسقه مع الهلال الاحمر المصري والجمعيات
الاخرى لدعم جميع المحتاجين في البلاد وفي
الخرطوم العائلات عالقه في منازلها
بانتظار الاجلاء نعمل ايضا مع الهلال
الاحمر السوداني والدولي لضمان استمرار
العمل في اكثر من 60 مستشفى وتزويدها
بالمواد الطبيه
وفي جديد الاخبار المتعلقه بعمليه الاجلاء
هيئه اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه فيما يتعل
عمليه الاجلاء الفرنسيه تقول بانهم انهينا
عمليه الاجلاء نحو جيبوتي وابقينا على
فرقاطه في بورت سودان لمساعده الامم
المتحده على عمليات الاجلاء نحو جده هذا
جديد الاخبار المتعلقه بعمليات الاجلاء
وفقه هيئه اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه نذهب الى
هذا الخبر حيث طلب باترك يوسف المدير
الاقليمي لافريقيا لدى اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر طالب الجيش ودعم السريع
باحترام هدنه وقف اطلاق النار والسماح
للفرق الامميه والانسانيه بالعمل وتقديم
المساعدات للمدنيين العالقين في منازلهم
منذ اندلاع المواجهات
خلال اتصالاتنا علمنا ان هناك عائلات في
الخرطوم لم تغادر منازلها منذ اكثر من
ثمانيه ايام والحركه بشكل عام في العاصمه
محدوده جدا يجب ان يكون هناك احترام لهدنه
وقف اطلاق النار من قبل الجيش والدعم
السريع ايضا سعدنا بنجاح عمليات الاجل
الاجانب وعليه ندعو المجتمع الدولي الى
الاستمرار ببذل الجهود وحث السودان على
احلال السلام والسماح للفرق الانسانيه
بالعمل خاصه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
والمتطوعين الذين يتعرضون لخطر كبير هناك
نداءات لحمايه المدنيين وفرقنا التي ظلت
عالقه في مكانها تفاديا للقصف تحدثنا مع
المسؤولين في جنيف والسودان للمساعده في
اعاده العمل في المستشفيات وتوفير المياه
والكهرباء
في اخر حصيله لها جراء الاشتباكات اعلنت
نقابه اطباء السودان عن ارتفاع عدد
الوفيات من المدنيين لاكثر من 290 حاله
وفاه ونحو 1700 حاله اصابه وقالت اللجنه
ان هذه الاعداد مرشحه للزياده لعدم قدره
النقابه على الوصول للمستشفيات لصعوبه
التنقل والوضع الامريكي في البلاد
هذا واظهرت مقاطع مصوره تصاعدا بعض اعمده
دخان في العاصمه وسط محاوله المدنيين
مغادره اماكن الاشتباكات الى مناطق اخرى
[موسيقى]
ازمه غذاء يبدو انها بدات تتكشف تباعا في
السودان اثر المواجهات المستمره بين الجيش
ودعم السريع حيث نفذت مواد غذائيه اساسيه
من متاجر العاصمه الخرطوم في ظل
الاشتباكات المستمره منذ 11 يوما هذا
وتضاعفت اسعار السلع الاساسيه المتوفره
وفق شهود عياد ورغم توقف معظم محطات
الوقود عن العمل في مدينه ام درمان لا
زالت طوابير السيارات تنتظر بجانب بعض
المحطات للحصول على الوقود
عايزين نمرق نمشي الولايات ما قادرين ما
لاقين بنزين وحتى ناس المواصلات نعم
التجلي بتاع مواصلات تقول لنا احنا مثلا
عايزين تذكره او كده التذكره غاليه جدا
يعني التذاكر بخمسه الف بقيت حتى لو لقينا
دكان فاتح هنايا منه حاجه لانه
في استغلال يعني حتى لو الباكو بتاع
الدقيقه الليله ب 8000 هيديك له قريبا من
محل هيديك بالف جنيه
بيقول لك انت مستقل عشان كده نحن اي حاجه
تقطع مني انا ما قاعد نجيبها والله يعني
من كل جهه لا كهرباء لا مويه لسه مخدرات
يمكن يشد علي هنا والخبز اهو زي ما انت
شايف
من اربعين دقيقه بين اربعين الى 60 دقيقه
ازمه الغذاء ليست الوحيده حيث عم الظلام
العاصمه الخرطوم بسبب انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي في ظل الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوه دعم السريع
المصائب لا تاتي فرادى حيث اعلنت شركه
ماركيه اكبر ناقله بحريه للحاويات اعلنت
وقفه تلقي حجوزات جديده البضائع الى
السودان بسبب الاشتباكات الدائره اضافت
شركه انها تراقب الوضع وتبحث عن حلول
لتحقيق الاستقرار في خدمه سلاسل التوريد
الخاصه بها هناك
التغطيه مستمره على العربيه ولكن نذهب الى
موجز سريع لاخبار متفرقه حول العالم
اعلن رئيس الاوكرانيه فولودي ان القوات
الروسيه قصفت متحفا في وسط مدينه كوبيانسك
الواقعه شرق البلاد الهجوم اسفر عن مقتل
شخص واصابه عشره اخرين مع وجود اخرين تحت
الانقاض هذا وقال حاكم المنطقه ان الاضرار
نجمت عن صاروخ الروسي مع نفي روسيا
استهداف المدنيين عمدا في عمليتها
العسكريه في اوكرانيا
اشار مسؤول بالخارجيه الروسيه
الى ان رد فعل الغرب على خطه روسيا في نشر
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه على اراضي بيلاروسيا
امر لا يهم موسكو قال دبلوماسيه ان موسكو
تهتم بمستوى ضمان امنها فقط وان روسيا
تهتم بنفس القدر الذي كان دول النيتو تهتم
بمخاوف روسيا فيما يخص الاسلحه النوويه
الامريكيه المنتشره في اوروبا منذ عقود
وصل وزير دفاع تركي خلوصياكار ورئيس
الاستخبارات هكا الى العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو للمشاركه في اجتماع يضم ايضا ايران
وسوريا ومن المرتقب ان يعقد وزراء دفاع
دول الاربع اجتماعا بمشاركه رؤساء
استخبارات ايضا
وهذه رئاسه اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه تتحدث
عن انتهاء عمليات الاجلاء من السودان نحو
جيبوتي اذا ساعدنا الاخباريه ضمن هذه
التغطيه المستمره في السودان على شاشه
العربيه لاخر تطورات المشهد والى هنا
تنتهي هذه الساعه الاخباريه وسيكون معكم
زميلنا في الاحمر بعد قليل تغطيه مستمره
ابقوا معنا على العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات